if you've had a go at this and you start
doing your outro and then you start
running into some brick walls okay and
so there's a trick to this what I'm
going to show you which this is why we
do these practice questions right
because you wouldn't have worked out
then you get this in again and you would
do your normal procedure and it breaks
down and you'll see what is it so starts
off pretty promising so I've got a point
and I've got these distances they're not
equal the sum of the differences English
- okay sure I'm going to have a distance
P a plus the distance P B and they
should equal two so far so good
okay now I've deliberately chosen some
nice easy numbers here okay because
despite that the algebra still turns
very bad because watch what happens
you've got the distance one minute he
puts the origin okay it's just gonna be
x squared plus y squared is that okay
because minus zero this time you've got
X -1 and y -1 and that's equal to 2 now
so far when you see square root signs
you like I'm gonna like deal with us so
I just Square okay and it seems like
gonna go okay first because this will
turn to just will you'll get rid of the
square sign right and this you also get
rid of square sign but then if you just
did that depending seems to be going
okay from there that's because you've
forgotten something something
significant right because a plus B oh
swing which you're squaring the whole
thing you're not picking water then
screen that and the next one right when
you square the whole thing it's not just
a square plus B Square
you have to double the product of the
two times and you're like oh no this is
gonna this is
this is going to turn out badly for me
right so this is going to be 2 times the
square root off so not only did we not
get rid of these square roots we made it
substantial couplet and don't even try
swearing again right because then you've
got Venus you've got three things you've
got a square and trust me is bad ok it's
worse so so this approach just squaring
it's not gonna help so join from this
line and squaring everything is it's not
going to get you any closer so what are
you doing you make one change and then
you keep on going which doesn't seem
like it would make that much of a
difference well so I'm going to take one
of these spirits and I'm going to move
it over to the other side sort of
doesn't matter which one okay I'm gonna
take I'm gonna take the easier one and
move it or not okay so I'm gonna have
this square root on this side and then
over the other side I'll have to - is
now what differences havoc um
all I've done is relocate things what
difference does it make answer or what
so now I can square it okay if I Square
this the square root sign disappears now
let's square this you're like that hold
on a second this is the same problem as
we had before
it is still a problem we will still have
a square root but it won't be as bad as
before because we wouldn't have square
root times square root watch what
happens
a square - sorry MSB or square square
the first one okay Square the last one
and then we take twice the product right
so in this case - - lots of two times
that so that's four
now I still have a square root I'm okay
but I can deal with this one okay
because when I when I expand this all
out you can see I'm gonna have an x
squared and a y square which will cancel
okay when I've simplified it further
then I can square again and that'll get
rid of the square root sign okay start
we'll have a look at I'll show you for
that now now when you get that at the
end it still will not be straightforward
it's still a weird shape okay so I'm
gonna leave you hanging in suspense same
question of the ball what's the shape
how did you describe it okay it's not of
it and can you can you graphics actually
draw okay and this is this there's a
catch here as well not just the script
see tomorrow